renewed warnings this morning about
threats against federal agents following
the fbi's search of former president
trump's florida estate those warnings
come as a clearer picture is emerging of
the man who tried to breach security at
an fbi office in ohio jeff pigues
reports
after january 6 navy and national guard
veteran ricky schiffer said that he was
at the capitol during the attack in his
social media post he wrote i was there
while he was not among the more than 860
people charged he appeared to be a
dedicated supporter of former president
trump after the fbi search of mar-a-lago
the 42-year-old from columbus posted on
trump's truth social
this time we must respond with force and
later wrote if you don't hear from me it
is true i tried attacking the fbi this
week trump supporters have taken to
social media to criticize the justice
department's actions florida governor
ron desantis called the fbi search the
weaponization of federal agencies
against the regime's political opponents
congressman paul gosar wrote we must
destroy the fbi on thursday schiffer
tried but failed to breach security in
an fbi field office in cincinnati he was
armed with a nail gun and an ar-15 style
weapon when law enforcement caught up to
him negotiations failed a shootout
ensued and he was killed tom o'connor is
a former fbi agent this is a very
dangerous time and
i hope that we can we can slow this down
and stop the the rhetoric which is going
to cause
violent actions against fbi agents or
fbi employees
late friday we learned
the fbi did get a tip about ricky
schiffer that he could pose a threat
still they didn't have anything specific
or credible to go on but they tried to
track him down unsuccessfully
until that deadly shootout on thursday
for cbs saturday morning jeff begaye is
in washington